yeah they don't like freedom of speech
in said but I'm telling you the best
thing you can do right now is um in
major sports is BET on the males playing
in the female sports you make a fortune
I'm telling you right now there's so
much money what sports I mean it would
be mostly what like there's soccer
there's baseball there's actually a lot
of fighting Sports actually you're
having a lot of like these mixed
martialarts I haven't seen it in the USC
yeah there's a there's a ton of women
that getting their ass beat bad I'm
talking about like bloody like up
and stuff like that there's a lot of
there's weird ones with track for some
reason track's another big one where you
have a lot of whes coming swimming
tournament my friend said she like hurt
her finger cuz the dude like hit so hard
really D yeah she'll be all right
but